[Music]
and up next from the national book
festival it's an author discussion on
covert operations
one of the authors you're going to see
tonight
is the washington post columnist david
ignatius
[Music]
[Music]
hi everybody i'm david ignatius a
columnist for the washington post
welcome to the national book festival in
this difficult time of the pandemic one
thing we can do and i know you're all
loving it as i am is to read good books
i wrote a book that was published this
summer the paladin which is about a ca
officer who's struggling with one of the
central problems of our time which is
knowing what's true
and what isn't
and it's my great pleasure to have with
me today two people who wrote
two of the very best books
of this summer about issues related to
our new
technologically sophisticated world and
the dangers first i want to introduce
bart gilman my former colleague at the
washington post
wrote an extraordinary memoir of his
dealings with edward snowden that led to
the revelations
about nsa technology and surveillance
and as the subtitle of bart's book says
the american surveillance state
and i also want to interview introduce
another outstanding author
thomas ridd
who teaches at johns hopkins
whose book active measures is a history
of what we have come to call
disinformation the ways in which
our election systems our politics our
very political fabric can be manipulated
by foreign governments and a history of
that kind of operation
going back many decades these are two
extraordinary books i'm delighted to
have
bart and tomas with me this morning and
i want to ask each of you if you begin
with a brief
one-minute summary of what you'd most
like readers
at this national book festival to know
about your books and then we'll go on to
a broader discussion but bart need us
all
dark mirror is uh
an attempt really to combine three books
it is
a story of edward snowden who he is
how he did what he did
why he did what he did
and it takes you
behind the scenes
of our interaction
uh journalist and source
it is a story
of the
surveillance state and the the uh
the content of the revelations that
snowden made about the nsa and the
change of boundaries
that it secretly
put into effect after 9 11
so that there were
there were there were lines that were
crossed after 9 11 that the american
people did not know about
and the third is uh is a more personal
memoir which i did not expect to write
but it's the story of in the
investigation the investigative
reporting that went into this uh it
brings you into the newsroom
um into uh moscow hotel rooms and and
into all the places
where i was doing my own reporting and
the dilemmas
uh and and risks and
in some cases dangers that i faced
i should say just in
closing
that opening discussion of dark mirror
that there's a way
readers that you'll find in in bart's
book
a modern highly technical version
of the sorts of
dilemmas and dramas that we associate
with all the
men stakes are high and bart takes us
inside the newsroom of
the 21st century not ben bradley's
newsroom but a different one
and i think that's one of the strongest
parts of the book
tomas
your book similarly is one that i had a
chance to
talk about with the public early in its
publication i think it's an
extraordinary book as i said in my
review of the washington post and i i
asked you just to describe a little bit
of what you were trying to do in this
broad look at the history of active
measures of disinformation over time
yeah i was in 2016 when the
election interference here in the
general election was
getting started in mid-june that year
the public facing side of it
i was investigating a russian hacking
campaign
an older one so i was closely paying
attention to russian computer network
operations at the time
and very quickly it became clear that
we're looking at a disinformation
operation literally within one day that
was
quite clear
and while i was able to understand most
of the technical forensic evidence
it very quickly became clear i was not
equipped to understand the history
i was not equipped to understand
the the the dynamics of what it means
when large intelligence organizations
develop
a
focus on on disinforming on shaping
narratives and interfering in public and
sometimes private conversations um
either
in a in a broad way or in a very
targeted way so that history was
ultimately what allowed me to
put into context what would happen in
2016
and uh and yeah i've spent about four
years writing that history
and tomas i think everyone in this
summer we're now left 100 days before
the
2020 us presidential election would want
to ask you
is this effort to manipulate our
politics from abroad and in particular
by russia
continuing in your judgment
it appears to be continuing but look at
the
2020 election from the perspective of
russian military intelligence or indeed
another russian intelligence any other
russian intelligence actor be it
government or private sector
they actually have a real problem
because
the expectation that a lot of people
have is that they will be aggressive
that they will be effective but they
will again try to
play this this game of political warfare
as cia called it in the 1950s
but so they're delivering against
extraordinary expectations and 2016 in
many ways was the perfect storm for them
a highly polarized situation we still
have that obviously but also nobody
expected
election interference in 2016.
not everybody but a lot of people are
expecting it today which to a degree but
only to a degree creates a certain
amount of
um
of
immunity or at least the defenses are up
today
so yes they're trying but probably it's
harder for them to succeed again
bart i want to turn this question to you
and ask you
to assess
the
foreign threats to american citizens
via computer technology
versus the thing that you focused on in
your reporting about edward stone and in
your book the american surveillance
state
is there a way for you to assess
the relative
danger external
from the kinds of people that tomas is
focused on in
moscow and internal in in in the
continued
efforts by nsa to collect information
around the world that may target
americans
there are very different kinds of
threats the external threat
landscape is broad
it
a lot of it has to do with straight-up
espionage
uh whether it's a commercial or uh
traditional american style uh
defense and national security espionage
so you have
many actors
uh some with criminal motivations uh and
uh
some with commercial
and some with security
who are uh who are
penetrating uh american uh computing
devices uh with phishing attacks and
other more sophisticated
methods and so they're breaking into
defense contractors they're breaking
into university research
they're breaking into
commercial processes they're breaking
into
covet research uh in order to gain uh
some sort of advantage and of course
there's a large number of of hackers who
are
looking to steal
personal information for identity theft
and for
financial theft there are
blackmailers who
who are coming after american
americans who they think can pay and
they're they're using ransomware to lock
up computers and threaten to destroy
information if a ransom is not paid
uh the threat from the nsa
is
um
more more of a of a shifting of
boundaries between the the government
and its own people in a democracy it's
the fact that
in the course of its surveillance of
foreigners uh the nsa has moved into the
large digital commons it's it's it is
surveilling large swaths of the internet
itself and in so doing
it inevitably uh pulls in huge volumes
of uh
us citizen and uh traffic
and so
that there we are we are being asked to
tolerate a level of surveillance over
americans
that we never had before
let me
press you to address the question that
you discussed
some in your book
but to put it in the most direct way do
you worry that the revelation of all of
the things that the nsa could do
all the capabilities
may have weakened
the united states ability to defend
itself against very aggressive and
increasingly sophisticated adversaries
i think there's no doubt that some of
the snowden revelations must have
reduced collection
must have interfered with
nsa operations
and
not least because
of the
opportunity cost the time
and personnel and money that was
expended
on mitigating against those risks
so
if you have
hundreds and hundreds of people in the
intelligence community who are occupied
full time
with
with learning what risks there have been
to collection and mitigating those and
finding alternate
um paths to the same information that's
those people are not doing something
else that they would normally have been
doing
um there are other ways in which
snowden's revelations
could be argued to have led to
collection losses but i don't know that
you could count that as damage under the
way our system operates that is to say
if the revelations led
consumers to demand greater privacy
because they didn't like
having their own data intercepted
and so then internet companies like
google
encrypted its connections
from google servers to your own servers
that can be said to have interfered with
nsa collection but that's that's the
marketplace working the way it's
supposed to if if citizens didn't like
some of what they were learning and
asked for legislative changes or brought
legal challenges in court that's the
system working the way it's supposed to
work uh and so a lot of the things that
uh that the intelligence community
regards as
damaging about snowden's
leaks is actually the system uh
responding
appropriately and according to our own
core principles of how we govern
ourselves
yeah if i may just quickly jumping to
jumping here
i also had the privilege to um review
barton's book in the washington post and
it was it's truly an impressive book and
in fact changed
my opinion and views on what edward
snowden did so which in some ways is the
highest compliment you can get as an
author but if you read his book next to
mine
there's really a question that leaps out
from that comparative read so to speak
and the question is how can it be
that the nsa has these really impressive
signal intelligence capabilities that
barton is talking about
yet
failed
and i say failed here in reference to
the entire u.s intelligence community
really
significantly if not spectacularly in
2016 in understanding an ongoing
election interference
before it happened and even in real time
because let's remember that the people
who were tracking it early on were
private sector companies crowdstrike
dell secure works and outside experts
not people in the intelligence community
at least
they didn't mention any any of their
early findings publicly and even in
hindsight i'm not convinced they
actually had their eyes on the ball so
what happened there it is a great
question
to some extent
i
can speculate that this
relates to you don't find something that
you're not looking for
i mean the nsa and the whole
intelligence community are governed by
an extensive and prioritized list of
questions
and topics that they're meant to be
meant to be looking at uh so it's
proliferation of nuclear weapons what
exactly is happening with
iran on
any of the following
subject areas and so on down the list
were they tasked and did they think to
look for outside interference in u.s
elections uh
there could be some doubt about that
bart i think this might be a useful time
to
ask you to share with our viewers
your sense of what edward snowden is
like
this is a an elusive personality for
most of us but he's somebody who really
has shaped the world that we live in
you've had the unusual opportunity to to
talk with him i'm guessing as much as
any other person except his wife
uh you've seen him in moscow just
describe for our national book festival
viewers
what he's like as a person what troubled
you what you admired what your takeaway
was
well he's a fascinating character he is
an autodidact uh he is someone who uh
follows his own rules uh if he's not
interested in something as a student he
doesn't pay any attention to it and and
gets terrible grades uh
he is he's tired of high school uh so
after
spending most of a year away
because of illness he never returns and
takes the ged instead which he
aces with flying colors
he teaches himself uh computer
techniques because he enjoys the
computer and he
signs up to take certification courses
for a bunch of advanced certifications
in the computer field
uh uh in including certified ethical
hacker that's one of my favorites
uh uh
in many cases without even taking the
course he just takes the exam uh and
he's got a sort of pretty natural
ability
to understand what the examiner is
looking for and and to answer the
question
um he takes a highly unusual route into
the intelligence community
starting off as a
nighttime security guard
and finding that is uh his talent for
computer uh
work is uh is accidentally discovered
he's encouraged to get a
a
microsoft certification and just to
start applying for jobs
in a community that doesn't care very
much about educational attainment but
cares what you can do
he is someone who has a very strong
and
unbending sense of what's right and
wrong
he is in that sense a zealot
as in my experience many whistleblowers
are
they
see the same things that other people
see
they judge them and they say that if if
no one else is going to do something
about this
then i am
he's capable of uh he can of being
funny uh
he will every now and then relax
and shoot the breeze and uh
talk about uh
sort of you know off-topic things but
he's unusually focused uh and quite
stubborn
uh about what he won't say
on the subjects that he's become best
known for
uh so i mean i i we had a fraught
relationship uh
and a lot of tension at the margins
uh about about what he would wouldn't
tell me and
uh there was one significant moment in
which i believed he had misled me
that led to another kind of
confrontation
if bart we had had a different
administration
come next year a different attorney
general
would you like to see
snowden allowed to come back and face
trial here in america
people i think would demand that in the
national security
community
and what
do you think the terms of that trial
should be should he be allowed to
make an argument that he really helped
more than he hurt how do you see that
going
well first of all i don't think it's
going to happen it certainly won't
happen voluntarily on his part uh
the charges he actually faces include
espionage
uh and
you can't sort of make up how you would
like a trial to go uh i mean it would be
it would fit his own sense of uh justice
and and i think i agree with him here if
he were able to mount a public interest
defense if he were able to try to
persuade a jury
uh that he had done more good that harm
that his intent had been uh
to advance the interests of of the
united states and his own citizens
but the way the law is written right now
the elements of the crime are that he
had
lawful access to classified material and
he gave it to someone who did not have
lawful access
that's it that's the whole crime
so he can't say
well it turns out that i i exposed some
legally doubtful operations even if
every single program he exposed had been
found to be unconstitutional by the
supreme court
he would still be guilty of espionage uh
under the terms of the law
uh and and so we are we're not going to
get the kind of trial in which he is
allowed to offer evidence of his
intentions or his actual effects on
security
turn to tomas and ask about the riddle
that i found most haunting in in your
book active measures
you go through a detailed and powerful
description of all the things that
russia over decades has done to try to
manipulate other other countries
but as you talk about
recent events the way america was turned
upside down
during the 2016 elections and since
you talk about the way in which
individual american citizens have been
the carriers of this disinformation
we've been the mules if you think of how
a drug cartel works who carry the
poisonous material back and forth if it
wasn't for us
for our amplifying spreading
disseminating these
russian tidbits it wouldn't have had
much effect
is that an accurate way to describe
where you end up in the book and
elaborate on that theme that
the underlying body politic is crucial
in how disinformation works
disinformation
is almost like a parasite it lives off
of an existing host
body politic
and what i mean by that is that
for example active measures would
exacerbate existing tensions existing
frictions
existing
contradictions in the you know old um
communist language that was emerged in
the 1920s it was
this information was designed to
exacerbate something that was already
existing
for example a highly polarized situation
in the 1970s running in the context of
the peace movement
between those in favor of strong
deterrence and nuclear weapons and those
against nuclear weapons soviets and
east germany for example study very much
tried to help the peace movement because
it ultimately served their interests to
criticize american
force modernization plans
so but that creates an intellectually
really difficult problem how do you
react
i'm going to suggest something unusual
look at this problem from the point of
view of the operator running an
operation of the
say the kgb in the cold war
if you're exacerbating an existing
phenomenon then how can you tell really
whether
you are
the cause of a certain development or
whether something was already happening
without you
so
i think what we're looking at today is
this situation that they're trying to um
especially now in 2020 that the russian
intelligence community continues to try
to take advantage of existing
debates and
frictions in the in the united states
but if we fall into the trap of
ascribing to their action
too much power for example if you think
or claim that
the russian election interference was
responsible for getting donald trump
elected
there's simply not enough evidence to
support that claim we cannot say for a
fact that they had an actual impact on
the outcome of the 2016 election but if
you make that call of judgment if you
say
i believe the russian election
interference is responsible for donald
trump winning the election at least
partly
then you are
ultimately helping them to achieve
that goal
so the in a nutshell
the the risk is that
the narrative about this information
becomes part of this information
we really are in a constructivist
nightmare here
so let me ask each of you to think uh
with all of us about what we can do
about the the threats that you've
described so well in your in your book
dark mirror and active measures
because our title is big brother is
watching i'm going to phrase it
what can we do to help the modern day
winston smith who was the hero of that
book
uh
resist fight back survive
amidst all of these technological
threats bart let me start with you and
i'll name some of the people who might
help winston then you can tell me if
they will or won't
obviously technology companies
conceivably could help protect us
but uh we're not sure whether that's a
good idea or bad
conceivably government
could help us protect protected citizens
but again
terrible problems in that regard
uh what what what way do you see
to
get the citizen
to take the united states
separate and first
uh better protection better security uh
how's that gonna happen
well if you conceive of the problem as
uh
as the
u.s government the us intelligence
community having
uh breached a line that he had
previously
uh been obliged to respect uh
into
uh surveillance of its own citizens
then
you have a number of possible actors
here the technology companies
have already
and quite deliberately done a
substantial amount
to restrict that
because
just about every website you go to now
is a secure website that's the https a
little lock
icon in your browser bar that wasn't the
case when snowden made his revelations
the whole internet has made that change
led by a few companies like google
whose
motives were explicitly
a desire to spend tens of millions of
dollars
possibly
an order of magnitude more than that
in order to thwart
bulk collection by its own government
uh which is a remarkable thing it hasn't
happened before the tech companies have
largely been cooperators uh and to some
extent still are and you could look at
it cynically and say
google facebook microsoft that their
their core attitude toward this is no
one gets to spy on our users but us
uh because there's a whole different set
of problems having to do with the
information economy and and the
surveillance economy uh in the private
sector uh you have other players uh you
know there there there are uh political
processes here with
with uh with uh ngos and lobbying groups
and uh
and political coalitions that are
demanding more privacy and and uh
achieving it to some extent in
legislative forums
there are
there are
litigators
who are challenging some of the lawful
basis
for some nsa operations
but fundamentally if citizens and
consumers in the marketplace are asking
for more privacy there is some chance
that they can get it
thomas i want to ask you to talk about
the
future threats beyond
the nightmares we've been discussing in
my new novel the paladin
i talk about the ways in which
computers can now create
video and sound imagery that is
so perfectly
woven together
that you can create a fake david or a
fake doll or a fake
joe
and it's very difficult to know the
difference between the fake and the real
so we're entering a new era in which
we're going to have to begin to put
quotation marks i fear around truth
until we've done our checking
and i want to ask as you as the
historian of of disinformation if you
will what do you think about this new
world of of deep fakes and the ability
to create not not fake news but fake
events how are we going to deal with
that i think in some ways the quality of
forgeries that we've seen during the
cold war was much higher than anything
that i've seen to date and of course
they used often technology almost always
technology that was
much more
hands-on but you can almost say that you
can't say that forgeries in the cold war
were artisanal whereas they are
industrial today at least that's how
leaks would work so the forgery
the quality of fortress that i'm seeing
today isn't there yet so the future
threat that you're describing is indeed
in the future for now
what i'm more concerned about is almost
the
threat of deep
uh denial as opposed to deep fakes
for example
imagine the access hollywood tip
you know where the candidate donald
trump used a
foul language
to describe women
um the access hollywood tape came out
today
he would be
you know he would simply deny its its
its authenticity
because it is credible and easy to forge
and fake his voice and and and so it's
easier to simply dismiss actual
uh evidence forensic evidence in a way
that was just not possible before so
there's this un unpleasant dangerous
flip side as well
but
what can we do about this i don't think
it will become impossible to draw the
line between facts and forgery in fact
what i'm seeing is an entire discipline
and an entire community of people's
emerging and that includes intelligence
officers includes law enforcement
includes investigative journalists
includes scholars open
source intelligence researchers who
really obsess about the quality of
forensic evidence of all kinds
through images
sound
digital forensics artifacts
and there's an obsession really with
facts and with the truth that of course
runs completely counter to the
prevalence of
saying
of lying that we see and disinformation
today but i'm hopeful i'm hopeful that
we will be in a position
to um
[Music]
to that that community that is emerging
of people who are who have the mindset
of investigative journalists
so to speak
um will be able to
teach others to really enjoy that moment
when you find a new piece of evidence
that leads you to revisit your existing
assumptions in a way that's you know
that's one of the greatest things of a
scholar and an investigative journalist
and and
i'm optimistic ultimately
could i just mention uh david that in
your own book
paladin
you've
come up with a near future scenario
and i don't want to spoil it here
in which
a deep fake
is
sophisticated enough
to fool a lot of people
in the short term and that it actually
doesn't matter to the purposes of the
fakers whether forensic evidence comes
along shortly thereafter that says well
maybe this thing isn't really true that
they've achieved their goal
simply by causing people to believe it
or believe it might be possible
even for just a few minutes
that's a problem that that isn't solved
by forensics
i i was thinking about about that
problem uh bart in the paladin and i put
to you uh the
conclusion that i've come to
and you tell me if if i'm being naive
here
in this world where it's so easy to
manipulate
to create false information that appears
to be real
the value of the truth no quotation
marks the true
reliable action the information that you
can trade upon in securities markets
that you can use to vote as a citizen in
our political case the value of that
truth will become much greater
and people will pay more for it because
it's so important to them
so
you know that gives me hope that the
market for what we do as journalists as
analysts is going to be is going to be
greater because people can't who are
going to die if they keep drinking from
a poisonous information stream
the second question this is one where
i'd like to ask barton and then tomas to
answer
we wonder whether technology companies
social media companies like google and
facebook should be more responsible be
more liable
for the truth or falsity of what they
put on their on their sites so there's
an argument that
you know
facebook should be like the washington
post if bart or i write an article and
somebody says that's not true
our paper can get sued because it
published it
should that case
apply as well to a social media company
like facebook which is going to have to
be liable for what it posts on its
platform bart what do you think
well that's a really interesting
question there uh
there are two issues there among
probably many others that that come to
mind for me
one is
uh that these internet companies
have
vigorously resisted that role uh for
legal and regulatory reasons if they are
public utility if they are
if they are essentially a neutral
conveyor of information the same as a
phone company um you don't hold the
phone company
liable for the fact that people make
telephone calls and buy
um or say untrue things or uh or do or
make damaging forms of speech so that's
that's that's the place they want to be
for legal and regulatory reasons uh if
you ask them to be
uh
as as
facebook says uh
it does not want to be an arbiter of
truth
uh you have to
try to imagine how that could be done at
scale with well over a billion users
and
god knows how many posts each day how
could they possibly
uh
be the arbiter of truth for for all that
many things and yet
they are
deliberately promoting
content in order to keep our attention
uh anything they can do to keep us for
10 seconds longer on a page
is valuable to them for their
advertising business
and their algorithms
take
the most extreme
content that gets the biggest rise out
of people and promotes that
and
and sells ads against it and so
uh you do want them to be much more
responsible with the way they use that
the same thing with youtube you you um
clicking about uh
uh a subject and next thing you know
you're uh you're watching videos that
are that are more and more insightful
more and more
extreme and uh and then you're locked
into a pattern in which
uh in which there's an interactive
uh process
of of radicalization
so uh tomas i'm gonna ask you to wrap up
this terrific discussion
uh by
taking your role as a historian of
of disinformation and and pull your
camera back uh i think uh 20 years from
now how we're going to look back on this
period we've been living through the
enormous
uh uproar over russian
disinformation efforts in the 2016
election and everything surrounding it
we look back and see this as a
as a beginning of a problem that got
worse that we never found a way to deal
with or will we over time get more
sophisticated subtle i want to say
cynical and and not be as disrupted by
these external athletes what's what's
your stance
[Music]
of course especially for anybody doing
hysterical historical work um you're
very cautious about predicting the
future
because we tend to get it wrong and
that's a historical statement
the
the the
the situation right now though the tool
overarching
threats and problems that i'm really
concerned about now are unrelated to
russian
election interference the first one is
the um
current administration the president
himself
laying the groundwork for calling the
legitimacy of the 2020 election into
question immediately afterwards he's
doing that in a systematic fashion
and he's not alone in preparing that
combine that
with a potential
uh
second wave of cobit 19 hitting us
exactly during that time frame in
october and november when the election
is going to happen
which in some way will or could support
the argument that the election was not
legitimate because it was so risky to go
out and vote in november difficult to
say
so that i think is a
pretty scary combination of
trends
in the covid situation however if i zoom
out
and try to be
optimistic uh you know i'm an immigrant
so i overcompensate on the optimism side
sometimes
but kovit in some ways is accelerating a
positive development also
and that is look at twitter and the way
twitter has handled misinformation on
kovid even coming from the president's
son and the president himself they took
action because now it's not just an
ideological argument whether speech
should be um somehow curtailed
now it's a a question of life and death
misinformation has become lethal and if
you don't believe in you know if you
think covert is a hoax you have a family
gathering and a couple of days later or
weeks later your mother-in-law
uh dies that is likely going to change
your perspective in a way that an
ideological conversation on social media
never would achieve
and we see stories like that coming up
now
so kovid
in a way david is is teasing out the
observation that you just made yourself
namely that the value of factually
correct information based on clinical
trials based on reliable research
and science is increasing
in the face of of misinformation and of
course in the face of such
extraordinary costs of getting
information wrong
well on that affirmation of the primacy
of fact i think it's a good time for us
to conclude this
conversation i want to thank our two
superb authors bart gilman
book dark mirror is a unique exploration
of edward snowden
uh what his case meant
what the future of
surveillance in america is and tomas
ridd whose book active measures is the
best history
of disinformation this effort to
alter the the basics of what we see and
think in politics that i've ever read
uh i'm david ignacio the author of a
novel called the paladin which looked
for some of these names from fictional
fair point we want to thank the national
book festival the theme this year is
american ingenuity
i think we got a pretty good
dose of the
techno
version of that as our two authors
helped us
walk our way through
some of the biggest issues
of 2020 so thanks very much ladies and
gentlemen and we'll hope to continue
with you at the festival
[Music]
and you're watching book tv on c-span